hello everybody welcome back to big
mood today we have one of our very
favorite returning guests
miss stacy diaz hi guys
thank you like i have to hold back so
much every time i see you the love is
mutual
oh she's our quintessential woman who
else do we have here on set for the
listeners what up it's gina
it's tiffany and then of course it's me
jess leading this episode here nikki
is um in the corner over there she is
our spectator
crying um she wished she was in this
video because she is
very much a pikmi girl
i'm kidding i'm kidding but yeah so
today our topic as you saw by the title
is pikmi girls
this is like kind of a new well not
super new but in the last couple years
it's like a
i don't know like an internet meme kind
of like a name there's a title for it
a title for a certain type of girl and i
felt like
we are the perfect show to talk about
this certain type of girl but i want to
say where i
found this initially was um there's this
youtube video that this lady named tara
mookney
tara mookney i don't know you guys can
look her up on youtube her video is
called the rise of the pikmi girl meme
uh when i first saw it she got like a
[ __ ] million views on this video it
went super viral then she took it down
like fixed something in it and then
re-put it back up and it got another 800
000 views so like this is a very viral
topic
so i feel like it'd be super interesting
for us to talk about like what our
opinion on that
is um yeah you guys watched the video
what was your just initial reaction do
you agree with tara
i agree like i there are women like that
out there and
i feel like all of us were this girl at
one point yeah i think that's pretty
fair just to say that at some point
yeah you know the whole time i was
watching the video i was thinking like
damn like
it it gave me flashbacks of moments in
like in my past of when i did have
certain thoughts that
aligned with this type of girl yeah and
i started feeling guilty
same [ __ ] dude like no way i'm totally
this kind of girl or like i have yeah
i had thoughts that put other women down
or whatever it is
and i started feeling bad but then
towards the end of the video she was
like
and i'm sure we've all had yeah thoughts
and i was like
okay this is like the way i see it is
like kind of like a self-correction for
the betterment
of women yeah it's funny the way she
starts the she opens the video i
actually wrote down when she opens the
video with she says we have an epidemic
of women doing obnoxious dick measuring
contests but instead of measuring their
dicks they're competing to see who can
set back women's rights the farthest and
i'm like
oh dude it's it's good though because i
feel like it takes women to check other
women
yeah um but yeah stacy did you have you
seen that video i have yeah she's really
good she has a lot of other good videos
yeah she's just like a really good
writer so i have seen it yeah and you
guys have to like even though we're
talking about this topic for an hour
like you have to go watch her video
because she has so many
like examples and like inserts yeah it's
like a really
put well put together video it's a long
video so you can just put it in like 1.2
speed
and just watch it really quick and just
get a lot of information really fast
[ __ ] i don't
i never watch anything at higher i do
but this one i decided not to because
all the pictures and images there's so
many images so i kept pausing to like
read everything that she had up there
because
she puts up she puts up statistics and
stuff
yeah i'm like [ __ ] i know you can't
read that fast i can
i'm really good at it yeah you're like
the internet the most internet of all of
us
but okay so on urban dictionary this is
the definition of a pygmy girl because
i'm sure a lot of people who haven't
heard this are still like okay what the
[ __ ] are y'all talking about yeah
a person who begs for the attention
acceptance and approval of a certain
group and different things they say
in most cases it's to attain the
attention acceptance and approval of the
opposite sex
this is this term is mostly applied to
straight women straight
females trying to get at men like
they're they're just
trying to do the most to get the
attention for men because i never hear
anyone saying
i'm not that kind of lesbian like
i mean there's probably different ways
that you could like put this out
into the world um for different but yeah
this is kind of just a straight
female term so everyone else can just
sit down and watch the straights
like essentially putting others down in
order for you to be
like the the best one because you're
like so you can get picked
yeah exactly so you can get pissed yeah
so it's like see these other people
are not as good as me so pick me she
said uh
in her video she was talking about how
that taylor swift song
you belong with me is the most pick me
[ __ ] song ever and i was just like
oh my god like it hit me i was like yeah
i used to love that song
yeah because i felt like i was like
you're like another one at first
i mean in high school i was a
cheerleader and all that stuff
eventually but i felt
at a point in my life i felt that i was
like i'm the [ __ ] like
i'm smarter i'm not this idiot you know
like you should be with me
the way i heard that song was more like
not like oh but i'm different pick me it
was more like
she's so pretty and i'm not and she's so
cool yeah i relate to that
i heard it as yeah but then the whole
course is you belong with me
but then there's also a line and she
says like i know you better than she
does
yeah is that this is that yeah yeah
she's putting the other girl down like
even if she's pretty she's a cheerleader
she's like a bimbo
yeah she doesn't understand you come
down to earth look at me i'll [ __ ]
serve you yeah
yeah i can't relate when i first heard
that song
i took it more as like uh the the one
that she was trying to get picked
or no that the prettier one was just so
like
not even interested in the guy that the
guy was just kind of like
like why even be with this girl like
that's how i respond
that's kind of true too like if he's
getting burned by the popular girl then
why
like why are you going for her i'll i'll
love you yeah
i interpreted that i feel like i would
get itchy if i ever
thought like that like she doesn't want
you but settle for me like right no
i have nothing to settle for yeah i
would just like no i couldn't
you know yeah that's so [ __ ] funny um
so uh we were talking about this before
the camera started rolling but nikki
loves this uh the part of the video
where she covers in logs which is
another term we have to learn today
which is not like
other girls so there's i guess another
uh internet meme about girls who
say oh i'm not like other girls like
have you guys ever said that
yeah when i was a teenager i feel like i
thought i've thought that before when i
was younger
have you um only when it came down to my
handwriting
oh god okay so neonatal you're allowed
to say that i'm not like other girls
i totally
i was like well i don't so i did feel
it was mainly like around middle school
age that i felt like oh [ __ ] like i'm
not like the other girls like
everyone else is like super cute all
cutesy like really
dressing really nice and all this [ __ ]
like the nicest [ __ ] handwriting
because like everyone in my school every
single girl had like freaking disney
like
beautiful those little asian girls have
the best handwriting ever
yeah i didn't really have any girls in
my school but yeah the other the rich
white girls had the cute handwriting and
i wasn't watching
all the toys in my school they had the
nicest [ __ ] handwriting
so then i was was it like that old
english
[Laughter]
i'm sorry the painting just fell on set
sorry are you talking to my girl lupita
from
high school i never treated you that way
that's stupid
but yeah i mean that's the time that i
did feel like oh i guess i'm not
like but you didn't do it in a
condescending way like you didn't think
you were above them like oh no
no right like no i always felt like i
was beneath all right i think that's the
core tenant of the in-law uh term
like against the pikmi is like the end
logs usually are a little bit they
they're not doing it in like uh oh i'm
better than type of way it's just like
oh man like i'm
i'm kind of boyish like i don't you know
i can't [ __ ] do makeup like other
girls like i can't do all this other
stuff like everything
i think it comes off the other way like
even though i can't do makeup
i love a natural look i don't i'm not
like
to me that's the negative like you
thinking like oh she like has such
pretty handwriting she looks so pretty
that's just admiring a woman to me but
you putting yourself above it and being
like
i'm not like other girls like i i'm just
better because i'm natural like i'm
better because i don't wear heels you
know like
or like well y'all are about to get it
uh twerking in the club yeah
at home like reading books man and
cooking that's the wifey one right
i think in the video they're the same
thing it seems pretty cool
like yeah so she was trying to say
there's a difference between not like
other girls and pygmies whereas like the
pygmies are just the more ferocious
version of the other girls you have to
put other girls down
not like the the end logs are more like
i'm not like the other girls that's
that's it but then i think like the
pygmies are the ones like
yeah i'm not like the other girls pick
i'm gonna put you down
yeah yeah yeah i'm better to shine
myself right i'm not like other girls
i'm better than other girls so pick me i
guess it's
like the escalation of that the more
extreme yeah yeah
yeah and then oh yeah because with the
with the end logs she was using a lot of
examples of like
yeah like the twerking one for example
where it's like well of course
a guy's not going to want to get with a
girl that's
just flaunting it all there like for
everyone to see
of course he's going to want someone
that's more conservative so that's like
which who [ __ ] made that up wasn't
steph curry's wife like that
yeah well yeah she got like burned on
the internet at one point what did she
say
she was something i don't know what it
was exactly she's something like i would
never show my skin
like that yeah she did say that i'm at
home cooking for my husband but
i think she felt like he cheated on her
i don't think steph curry has ever
cheated on her
but now every time she posts like a
picture even in a bikini
people are like i thought you didn't
show any skin like what's happening
she just kept her mouth shut i think
okay so something some backstory to that
is
her and steph curry met at like a church
group when they were like 16 and 17.
so they grew up heavily in the church
when which when you're in the church
you're taught that way you know like
you're not gonna be worthy if you show
yourself you're not gonna
you're not gonna go for can you just
take it out
our producer assistant producer over
here not to make noise it's hilarious
he's making more noise yeah sorry stacy
no no worries
yeah but i mean i think that comes with
that backstory but of course the
internet took it and ran with it like so
now every time that
she is more into herself now she wears
like the low
crop tops and things like that people
are just still holding her to the same
standard
because she put herself as the example
to follow like if you want to find
husband
you have to be like me and that's the
wifey category one right
that's that is kind of part of the pick
me culture
as tara was explaining to us
um and i feel like that's that's so
shitty because she said that years ago
people are allowed to change their minds
of course people are allowed to go
internet won't let you
yeah but they won't they they'll hold
you accountable for something the
internet never forgets
the internet never forgets dude that
shit's so annoying
because like yeah it's so true because
you could grow as a person have
different opinions like
dude especially you know like we've been
on on social media for such a long time
and we've had so many different opinions
throughout time but then it's like oh no
but didn't you say this one thing 10
years ago
how are you not still yeah and then
they're like oh you're just a hypocrite
or you make [ __ ] up
because like you evolve or you change
over time so then they're just like oh
you're just making [ __ ] up or you're a
hypocrite but if you're on the internet
you're going to be a hypocrite at some
point
literally if you're alive you're a
hypocrite at some point the entire world
exists it just we all are hypocrites
cause like i'll be in traffic
and they'll be like a long line and
people are trying to cut and i'm like
don't let that [ __ ] in like you
do not [ __ ] cut but when i'm in a
hurry i'm like trying to [ __ ] cut
yeah i'm a hypocrite i am a hypocrite
probably every day in some way
so we need to just get over that [ __ ] um
there was also in the video she was
trying to
talk about um like how on the guy
side we have this nice guy term where
they're like oh yeah
you know they're all um there's it
sounds like it would be a good thing but
they're just trying to be nice so that
they can get sex but when they don't
or when the girl rejects them then they
start getting kind of aggressive about
it but like
yeah there's not she was saying in this
video there's not really like a female
equivalent of that
because you mean no female equivalent of
the nice guy
because girls if you want to be like
super
um i don't know stereotypical tend to
not be as violent
or like reactionary like violent whereas
some nice guys
uh i guess could be more aggressive yeah
and so girls tend to turn
that kind of resentment in on themselves
whereas the guys will take that
resentment out on the world yeah
so that's pretty i thought that was
pretty interesting like all these stupid
little internet like
titles and stuff are weird but it does
kind of help you think about like
behavior in people um do you
think that there's any women that get
aggressive when they get rejected
i don't know have you been like it's
kind of interesting
no i think because even if let's say a
man rejects me and i try to like
physically go against him chances are
even though i'm like taller than the
average woman he'll kick my ass
because like the average dude is
stronger than stallion then
yeah like any strong woman but um
physically speaking but it's kind of
interesting how like
the man if he gets rejected he throws
anger at the woman
and the woman in order to get picked and
not get rejected
she is throwing anger at women as well
yeah
so she's like deflecting it yeah other
women yeah like okay well pick me
because i am not like her
and the man is like well you didn't pick
me so i'm just now gonna you're ugly i
attack you
yeah like you're [ __ ] fat and ugly
anyway like okay [ __ ] what about you
so we're getting attacked everywhere
yeah what about like the
the story of the girls that like key the
car they like
you know bash out the windshield and all
that [ __ ] like whatever
cheated on right isn't that a form of
rejection like do you think that that
counts that's almost like no i don't
think rejection
cheating is not rejection we had an
agreement you didn't reject me
you went out of the agreement does it
feel like rejection though no it feels
like betrayal yeah
it doesn't feel like rejection because
you wouldn't be in a relationship
with me i think a rejection would be
like i try to sleep with my
boyfriend or let's say we're in a
relationship
and you tell me like i don't want to
have sex with you anymore but we're
still together and then i go key your
car
like who does that right you know like
you rejecting me has never caused that
you betraying me
has caused that you know yeah i guess
it's a different kind of revenge like
the guys are hating because they can't
get it before they're even in they're
entitled
yeah before they're they're entitled to
you they're like you're not gonna give
me your time even though i've been nice
yeah how dare you that's the difference
where the girl has had their
relationship
then gets betrayed and then attacks i
always thought it was so funny it's like
hey girl you're so hot can i get your
number no thanks well you're [ __ ]
ugly anyways it's like
yeah make sure you guys ever had that
happen too
age range that i'm in they find a new
thing so now that i'm over 30 it's like
well you're [ __ ] old anyway nobody
wants your ass
like so where are you guys getting hit
on like at the bar the internet
usually the internet the information at
one point
yeah this guy was like hey girl what's
up get your number i'm like trust me i'm
not your type
he goes well you're [ __ ] ugly anyways
and i yelled back like then why the [ __ ]
did you hit on me and then he ran inside
he ran i've had maybe in public like two
or three times max like mostly during my
party days like where i'd be you know
yeah drunk guys yeah yeah same i mean
yeah it'd be like out of the club or
sometimes in mexico would be
walking down the street like dude
because you know they're always [ __ ]
cat calling
yeah yeah sister would like she would
tell me like some some
comebacks for like certain ones where
it's like hi chiquita i'm like latinas
pendejo and then they'd be like yeah
but i guess like that's not directly
like back up what you look like
you know like like that's kind of like a
banter of like yeah
if i can play well then it's like [ __ ]
you then yeah it's not like you're
[ __ ] fat it's more like
[ __ ] you then well and that i'm okay
with like okay that makes more sense
i'm going to [ __ ] myself if my attitude
is like
hey [ __ ] off i don't want you to hit on
yeah yeah for them to be like all right
well then go [ __ ] yourself too yeah yeah
but if it's like
oh well you're ugly it's like that's
clearly a lie because why would you be
trying
you told me in the first place like
really it's happening like it's never
happened to me in real life
on the internet it probably has but in
real life on the internet
on the internet yeah like i love talking
[ __ ] in your comments in the internet oh
my
gina is the best person
ever that has happened ever stacey will
just be tweeting someone like
these [ __ ] are talking [ __ ] in my
comments i'm like say less
do you get more hate from women or men
yes from women right
first of all my whole content is
uplifting women right
that is my whole comment that's what's
confusing for me but maybe they're
[ __ ] pick me ass [ __ ] let's hear
but i think my analogy is that because
i am giving you tough love because love
is to grow right like when i go to
therapy my therapist is not just like
you're right all the time like
so i'm pointing things out and i think
sometimes that may trigger people
and so they're like well you're this
this and that how do you dare to talk
when you're
that this and that you know and so even
when they talk [ __ ] like i never go back
and talk [ __ ] to them
it's very weird but then gina comes in
and she's like well [ __ ] you [ __ ] and
i'm like
i'm a mouthpiece i'm a mouthpiece yeah
she really is i mean
it all depends on what kind of image you
want to give you know like
i am the angry interpreter yeah like
i'm luther yeah yeah but what were we
gonna say i was gonna say like what's an
example of something that you hear the
most from women that are that are mad at
you oh my god
oh my god she preaches about beauty and
loving herself but she gets work done
yeah like this [ __ ] has it like in the
background
yeah but like that's one of them you
know or like there'll be anything
anything i've ever said
you know like one time i made a tick
tock video talking about how i
personally me
stay cds i would not date somebody who
has kids
and i said why and i was obviously
speaking about men because i date men
and a bunch of single moms came and
attacked me right and i'm like [ __ ] i
wasn't even talking about you
you know like but obviously everything
on the internet that you ever watch
when do you not personalize it when are
you watching something and you're like
oh this must be about somebody else
no if you're a single mom and you're
watching that you're like this [ __ ] is
talking [ __ ] about me
right you know and so i kind of try to
understand that you know and i try to
just separate myself from it it's hard
as somebody who feels a lot
it's hard but um yeah it's i get it all
the time the majority of my audience 90
of my audience on youtube is women so of
course the majority of my quote-unquote
hateful comments are going to come from
women right
so that's something that i'm just okay
with you know yeah we were just talking
about the other day like
i was just telling the girls like i love
stacey's concept but i wish i understood
i want to understand so bad but i don't
know
subtitles like tik tok get on that but
the spanglish thing i just can't help it
it sounds better in spanish
totally i translated it i'm like this
doesn't make sense in english
yeah like you guys are gonna think it's
weird and it just comes out with more
passion
you know
because i'm like dead speak in english
then i'm like oh wait yeah yeah
also can't say this i can't say that
that's why you just said you can't do
that you can't say that
i i'm quietly feeling left out i'm like
yeah i'm not racist i just want to
understand maybe i can start tweeting
like
in spanglish and then like the english
translation right below it
and plus on tick tock your numbers do
better if you put captions so you have
to type it out
and you can put like tick tock is
finally getting like the
speak to like writing captions so that's
something cool they're just not doing it
in spanish yet
speaking of um cat calls i just want to
bring this back for a second my favorite
reply to a cackle because i
[ __ ] hate it so much uh if a guy's
being creepy he's cat calling you just
be like
oh i'm sorry i don't have any change and
then they're like
that's good yeah you might not have any
change but
do you want to change your clothes
spring season
and i don't want to work too hard on it
well do i have a service for you
this episode is brought to you by stitch
fix i'm actually wearing shoes that i
got from stitch fix
um i point these out in the last few
episodes because i actually really like
these shoes i'm still trying to break
them in they're brand new
these are michael kors boots i don't
normally buy michael kors purses because
i'm a hater
but i like michael kors shoes
[Laughter]
she's being a pigment yeah
brought you [ __ ] that wear michael
kors purses no i'm just kidding um
but anyways uh online shopping can be
daunting you never know if things will
fit returns are difficult you don't even
know what store to start with well if
you're like me
because i'm not like other girls
i don't know how to shop i'm not like
other girls this season let stitch fix
do all the hard work for you
um stitchfix offers clothing hand
selected by expert stylist for your
unique size style and budget it's
completely different and fun way to find
clothes you will love to wear
every piece is chosen for your fit and
life and it's easy solution
to finding what makes you look good and
feel your best you can try on all the
stuff
um you could it's really easy to send
back they send you the return
bag along with it so you try it on
whatever you don't like just put in the
bag and
take it to the post office that makes it
so easy
it's super easy shipping things they
just give you a bag throw it in their
seal everything the labels on there you
just yeah throw it out it's easy prepaid
return envelope is included there's no
subscription required
they started out that way but you don't
have to do that anymore you could try it
once or you could set up your automatic
deliveries
you'll pay just 20 styling fee for each
box which gets credited toward the
pieces you keep and there are no
other hidden fees ever get started today
at stitchfix.com
mood you'll get 25 off when you keep
everything in your fix
that's stitchfix.com mood for 25
off when you keep everything in your fix
one more time
[Music]
stitchfix.com okay i'm really glad that
we got this sponsor it's one of my most
favorite things and i have it at home
and people try to steal it from me all
the time
we have fair gun oh the most legit
massager ever so good um don't let the
stress of daily life weigh on your body
whether you're an elite
athlete right okay or someone like me
or someone like me i've been using it on
my freaking my bed sores because like
what are your aids all day
yeah dude because i'm like i'm either
sitting down or laying in bed
so like my lower back like really really
lower back or upper butt area is
always so hurting but then i use their
gun and
like melt it all the way i love it so
there again can help uh there again is a
handheld percussive therapy device that
releases your deepest
muscle tension using a scientifically
calibrated combo of depth
speed and power and it says it's as
quiet as an electric toothbrush
i actually had the older version of it
like years ago and it was so loud it was
dumb because i
for the first time i tried to use it in
the middle of the night i was just like
i'm awake let's open this up
i was like right when i turned on i was
like oh no
but now that i got this one it's a lot
quicker technology has gotten better
yeah um the gen fourth air gun doesn't
just feel good it gets the source of the
pain by releasing tension
using their again signature percussive
therapy which goes 60
deeper than vibration alone that thing
gets
in there the sounds that i make
[Music]
[Laughter]
animal sounds it's very concerning how
do i get one of these
yeah uh whether you want to treat your
muscle tension from working out or
an injury or just the stresses of
everyday life there's no substitute for
the theragun gen 4.
the oled screen and design makes you
feel like you're holding something from
the future
just go to their site and check it out
and the theragan app learns from your
behaviors and suggests routine
or guided routines you can try the
theragun for 30 days starting at only
199
dollars go to theracon.com mood right
now to get your gen fourth air gun today
that's theirgun.com mood one more time
that's theragun.com
mood i love this thing so much now in
that video too she was talking about
there being different types
of pikmis yeah so we covered the
n logs well the end logs are i guess
like the least form
like she kind of didn't she tried to
exclude them from being pygmies but they
kind of still
are they're like there's a there's like
pikmi girls in the gaming industry too
girl for sure i mean i feel like that's
like such a huge portion or at least the
end logs like i'm not like other girls i
play video games
it's it's more because because the video
game industry is so male dominated for
so long there's bound to be pikmi girls
there right
so um there's girls that are like i
don't need to show
skin while streaming to get viewers i'm
not like other girls
see girls you don't have to show skin or
wear something with cleavage to get
viewers
you can do it on your own just wearing
whatever you know cover it up too
but thankfully though nowadays when
someone comes out and says that
they get burned immediately really oh
like how [ __ ] dare you first of all
like you let women where the [ __ ]
wha where whatever the [ __ ] they want
and i'll even get men come into my chat
and be like oh wow it's so refreshing to
see a girl that's not showing cleveland
cleavage to get views rose on their
stream they're just haters because
girls are like doing well in an industry
that's supposed to be for men
yeah so men will come into my chat
saying i respect you for not showing
skin and i call them out immediately and
like that's not
a compliment right i respect those girls
like they can wear whatever
whatever the [ __ ] they want because
they're making bank you know so that's
not a compliment don't come into my chat
saying that [ __ ] go and accept every
woman no matter what they're wearing on
stream
yeah i wonder um i mean do you think
that their motivation
behind those kind of comments is at
least
could potentially come from somewhere
good where they're like like you know we
don't have to be
hookers or whatever in order to be
successful in a male dominate like so is
it just the way that they're going about
it
i think that's i think they mean it in a
it comes from a good place it just comes
off wrong
because it comes from a good place
shaming right yeah even though you want
to uplift women you're also kind of
slut-shaming
it's like the same thing right for me
it's more like do whatever the hell you
want you know
whatever the [ __ ] you want you're not
harming anyone um so i think it comes
from a good place it just
it just just to shut up about it you
know like
you don't have to put your opinion about
it about it out there um
i know you're trying to uplift women be
like look you don't have to do this you
don't have to do that
but at the same time it came off as
putting the women down
because that's what it was yeah exactly
i mean i've always kind of thought about
it like don't give me a compliment if
it's putting someone else down
i don't need that you know because if
she's showing cleavage if she looks
great
and if she's getting attention and the
attention that she wants to get
let her you know like tell me how pretty
my hair is tell me how pretty i am you
don't need to put
anyone else down partially like women
kind of
had to start there in order to get into
some industries anyway like
gamer girls probably had like that was
the novelty like no one was going to
listen to a [ __ ] girl about video
games because like they don't know [ __ ]
right that was the that was the whole
like the way the industry started
but if a girl has big titties big
cleavage cute face
like big eyes and she's playing video
games for men that's a novelty so then
now all of a sudden you know she broke
into the industry
by i guess dangling a carrot in front of
men's eyes but then that kind of opened
the door a little bit more for the other
women do you think that's
possible it could have been it could
have been but at the other hand there's
also
like who were the first women streamers
that were [ __ ] huge were they titty
streamers or were they literally like
competitive no like pokey pokeyman we
had her before
she got in because yeah she's cute she
makes the point to not show any skin but
also she's insanely good
you know so she's she's completely she
is one of the first and she she was
completely like talent-based yeah
because at that point you're saying
something like well we're only really
here to be like eye candy
well i'm just wondering if that's how
you break in if that's if that's a way
that women
have been able to break in into the
using it for our advantage
like yeah is that i mean because a lot
of times men won't respect women's
opinion in an industry that they've
never had
experience and so like how do we break
in it's tough because i kind of have a
little bit of experience obviously not
in the gaming world
but um i used to be in the fitness world
right and so that's how i kind of broke
into
the internet stuff that i do now and
i've spoken about this before i
literally have a
whole video talking about how i started
dressing more modestly right
and a lot of these modest videos are
like christian based like girls start
dressing more modestly because of their
religion
and that wasn't the case for me like i
do love god and i have a great
relationship but that wasn't my
intention
and i realized throughout the years that
when i was younger
i was showing skin literally working out
and like
little spandex and a sports bra
purposely putting my phone on certain
angles that would make me look thicker
to get views to get comments to get
engagement because that meant more
money more followers more viewers you
know
and i even went further to say like when
i was getting those kind of
viewers like it's not like you get in
and
when men think that you're a hot piece
of meat that's all they think about you
you know so it's not really helping your
it wasn't really helping my career
because
they would like let's say i posted a
like a picture of me working out on
sports bra in spandex and then the next
post was like hey guys
um i don't know like here's this really
cool makeup look that i did
then like 10 000 likes to like 100 likes
you know so they weren't liking what
they were like no we want to see you
naked
yeah you know so for a while it took me
a long time to where i was like you know
what
[ __ ] it i'm gonna stop showing skin
whoever has to fall off is gonna fall
off and i'm gonna do
what i think is best for me and so
that's
like two weeks and a half three years
ago that's when i started posting
content for girls
and of course it's not just for girls
anybody can for the gays on the days and
right you know but i was like a victim
of that where i was like if i need to if
i want to get followers i need to show
skin
and it wasn't until i did it for so long
that i was like i actually don't feel
good about myself when i do this
and i'm not getting the kind of like
views comments and followers that i
actually want so let me try something
else i think that's a huge trap that a
lot of
that a lot of girls have fallen into
because they they see that that will get
you a lot of the views but
they're empty views they're not real
fans they don't give a [ __ ] about what
you
think for sure you can't really turn
that into money unless it's like you're
just going straight into
uh playboy or like well it's not just a
male dominated
audience that's just paying for your
body that's that's where that audience
is
going and not even like the money
because like of course the money is nice
but the relationship i have with my
subscribers and followers now
where i get messages and girls are like
dude like you helped me start therapy
or like i left this piece of [ __ ] dude
or whatever like i feel
like i'm strong and i'm deserving of
love when i get those messages compared
to the messages i used to get before
like oh you're so hot
or like oh like i want to show you my
dick
yeah like before it wasn't it wasn't an
engaging thing now i feel like i'm
i'm a family with my audience and i feel
like i'm truly
making a change in people's lives which
is what i wanted to do
if you want to show your ass in titties
and make money from that go ahead i have
nothing wrong with that but it just
wasn't what i wanted to do you know
so i'm the opposite i feel like um i'm
not the exact opposite but i started off
like that too
you know you could show i was a model
yeah
um but i saw it as this is building my
audience right now
and i support any woman's like yo if
that's gonna make you money
and it's not harming anyone go do it
build your audience i still support that
yeah
so i built my initial audience and i
knew what i was doing
you know like i knew the photos that i'm
taking the [ __ ] that i'm posting
it's gonna build my audience build build
build build build i have that now
let's show some personality and uh
a lot of people are like oh that's
[ __ ] cool she's just not
tits in a face it's i was gonna say ass
but you know we don't have that
um
[Laughter]
and then that's when personality i can
start leveraging
that those those views those numbers
that i got
now i can show you my personality a
little bit more um i don't have to
post as many thirst traps so i used it
as just like a base to build really
quick
and then start you know branching out
from there
now i don't have to post as much and
then now that i've built a solid
foundation
i'm just like i can post whatever the
[ __ ] i want now and my my followers are
there and then i started
um being able to show my
my my stupid ass personality more but
i did use my face my body my sex appeal
because
i mean it's it's as old as time sex
cells right yeah that's just
for sure right um yeah which kind of
goes back to what jess was saying
earlier where it's like well maybe in
the gaming industry like that's
how they saw themselves like this is the
only way i'm going to open this door
yeah it's not it's definitely not you
know um
but i do feel like women shouldn't be
shamed for using
what they have yeah i don't think yeah i
don't see it as
shaming at all yeah oh no i don't
believe you're shaming but there are
people out there that should they do
yeah for sure it's probably like an
insecure type of
reaction right like i mean any woman
that puts another woman down the
the only reason i can think of is just
insecurity but for sure
as far as like yeah like us
being in a media setting like using your
body to get an
audience or not like is there some girls
and this is not to be mean there are
some girls that literally don't have a
personality but
they're still entertaining because
they're great models like they still
have a they're
perfectly accepted and well needed in
our
in our entertainment industry or
whatever it's not harming anyone no it's
not
yeah like and they're making hella money
like especially on only fans and stuff
like that too
yeah i have an issue with only fans
because i feel like a lot of guys that
are in relationships are spending way
too much money on it but like i wouldn't
my hate for only fans is never on the
girls like
working yeah not on the sex workers i
don't have any hate for them because
like they they
got to their point in life and they felt
like that was their option that was
their best option like i
i'm a supportive woman in any [ __ ]
way i can
but i just yeah anytime i've ever talked
about only fans i think more my issue is
just like why are all these guys that
are married in relationships spending
like hundreds of dollars on those direct
accounts it feels a little weird for me
i feel like it's better for single guys
than it is for relationships but yeah
anyway but these girls are making
[ __ ] 80 000 a month yeah and do your
thing
if that's what you want to do [ __ ] yeah
i'm over here clapping for you go ahead
so thank you to bring it back now to the
pikmi girl stuff like there's um
i guess one characteristic of that which
is the wifey
this is like an archetype of the wifey
so they um apparently what they like to
do is push these archaic gender roles
making their whole life about serving
their man
um like it's like they're all above
their own
bringing us back yeah those are the
worst i think and those
a lot of those actually are the biggest
haters of the only fans girls because
they're like they're not they're not
going to marry you like you're selling
your [ __ ] [ __ ] on the internet like
so i'm going to marry that
um ask somebody i love my man and i do
want to have a life where i
you know uplift them because obviously i
picked them and i'm proud of him
right so i take pride in what i do for
work i love my job i love my businesses
but there are women who strive to be
housewives
right that is what they want to do they
want to be makers that's okay they want
to be
stay-at-home moms they want to cook and
clean and like get up early for their
men
yeah so what is the difference between
somebody who genuinely wants to be a
homemaker
and somebody who's like setting women
back a thousand years the women that are
putting them putting them down so like
not letting women be free to choose
their life so like got it
the ones that are like oh you're not
gonna get a man you don't deserve a man
like you're gonna be you're gonna die
alone you're gonna be a cat lady
and this is why because you're not doing
what i'm doing i'm [ __ ] slaving away
all day the only way to get a man is to
make sure that macaroni and cheese is
nice and [ __ ] moist
like you don't you don't have to do like
you can be
i'm this and that's it i am yeah i love
being a homemaker period
and that's got it i'm i'm totally down
for that like
i don't want to work a lot either i
don't want to be like a homemaker
my sister does too i admire we need
homemakers in this world yeah i mean
obviously we need women that are want to
stay home and raise the kids
yeah it's a beautiful life yeah it's
just not for me but yeah right same but
i struggled with this in my later 20s
because um
growing up as a vietnamese girl in a
traditional vietnamese family i was
raised to be a wife
like this is what you do this is like i
remember like them teaching me when you
sit down and i still do it to this day
when you sit down and couch you don't
just
you know you sit gently you're a wife no
one taught me that
you know like so i was always taught to
be like this soft dainty wife how to
cook how to clean i know how to do all
that [ __ ]
but then growing up in america in
america
yeah so now i'm hearing like oh no women
shouldn't be housewives
so so in my 20s i was confused i'm like
i i secretly want to be that wife but
people are telling me that it's not okay
so i didn't know i thought i was doing
wrong you know like the feminist
movement i was like am i wrong for this
and then later on i was like no the
feminist movement thing is you do
whatever the [ __ ] you want to do yeah if
that includes being housewives exactly
and i would love to be that you know i
hope you get that i think
i think a lot of what happened too is
like when you're fighting for something
a lot of times you have to
um like swing the bat a little too hard
in order to just get the ball to go a
little
ways so like we see that with a lot of
movements yeah right now there's
just a lot of radical movements because
you're just trying to get the
the ball to move a little bit but
sometimes you have to swing super hard
to get it to move a little bit so like
when feminists are like oh you should
never be a housewife never
this never that like i think they're
just trying to get us to a place where
we can be free to choose
in general but it does go too far when
they're like putting down women that
want to be stay-at-home moms and stuff
like that's a big part of culture that
doesn't need to completely disappear
yeah like if women enjoy it let them
just how we're allowing and pushing the
only fans girls
that's allowing push to stay at home
wife so i have another question yeah
so you know you and i relate in the
sense that we love working right like we
love working it's something that
fulfills us so if i wanted to let's say
i was like i want to be a stay-at-home
wife that's my life calling right
and you were telling me like oh my god
i'm starting this business and i'm so
passionate about it
and i just can't wait and like if a man
comes along that'd be great but if he
doesn't like it's okay yeah let's say
you're saying that and that's kind of
what i am saying
okay so let's pretend you're talking and
you're saying that and i'm sitting here
and i'm like
no can't relate honey can't really like
it just it's i don't see how you could
ever
like is that being a wifey pikmi girl or
is that just being like not supportive
of your life and dreams
if you keep it to yourself if you keep
it to yourself oh no [ __ ] i'm telling
you like i'm like
so somebody be telling me yeah it's kind
of like i can't personally relate
but it's like good for you then that's
kind of different that's not being a
pick me no
i think the pikmi stuff comes into play
when it's like you're grand standing in
front of the world where you're like i
am better
than this [ __ ] because she just wants
to go out and work you know she's not
even going to raise your kids she has no
value as a woman like what is she doing
you pick me because i'm the homemaker
right like i will make sure your shit's
taken care of i'll
[ __ ] clean your [ __ ] stains you know
what i mean but the thing that
bothers me the most about that is when
those house maker woman take it too far
and tara pointed this out is that the
the wife becomes the second mother and
the man
is infantilized so he turns into a baby
yeah and that relationship dynamic loses
its sexual appeal
and loses its longevity so a lot of
those men go out and cheat
anyway even though you [ __ ] served
and gave them your whole life
because you just turn into their mom
exactly and they don't want to [ __ ]
their mom
but they'll and you don't want to [ __ ]
your son no it's
i hope not so yeah
um there was i was looking up this term
i'm sorry there i was looking at this
term i think it's called hotep or
something but i saw it
uh on black twitter and basically i i
don't know if that's the right term but
it's basically a woman who
excuses a man's terrible behaviors
because they blame it on the woman
for example well maybe you know you
shouldn't be mad at him for cheating
because if you were a good wife
yeah that's um that's something that's
not
toxic [ __ ] that's toxic we need to wash
that away and what else can we
wash with our function of beauty we can
wash our hair
we can wash our hair we got to take a
take a quick
break because when you're cooking food
all day for your man or yourself
whatever yeah your hair will smell like
onions and garlic girl you got to wash
the onions and garlic out and keep your
man happy
and if you need a good shampoo actually
have it right now the rose one i smell
[ __ ] great
we have function of beauty which is the
world leader in customizable beauty
offering precise formulations for your
hair specific needs
i really like this because i like taking
quizzes and you go on their website and
you take a quiz you tell them
what's wrong with your hair and what you
want to fix about it and they will
formulate
a shampoo and conditioner combo just for
you
you can choose the color in the
fragrance or you can go fragrance and
die free personally i have the purple
one and it's in rose
you can even choose the intensity of the
smell and i put strong because i want to
smell like a [ __ ] field of flowers
um every ingredient function beta uses
is vegan and cruelty free
and they never use sulfates or parabens
you can also go completely silicone free
there are over 54 trillion possible
formulations and function of beauty has
over
real 50 000 5 star reviews and function
of beauty offers completely personalized
formulas for body and skin care as well
so you can customize your beauty routine
from hair to toe i like that
never buy off the shelf just to be
disappointed ever again go to
functionalbeauty.com
big mood to take your quiz and save 20
off your first order
that applies to their full range of
customized hair skin and body products
go to functionalbeauty.com big mood to
let them know that we sent you
yeah do that because it helps us a lot
and to get 20
off your order again that's
functionalbeauty.com
big mood and after you shower you're
nice and clean you're feeling great
about yourself right
but if you don't have such a very nice
smile you end up not really feeling good
about yourself sometimes right you don't
feel like you're smiling you're just you
kind of want to like
cover your teeth never throwing up gang
signs yeah exactly
let's close crips yeah but uh so
if you're feeling that way candid can
help you so candid is the clear
comfortable removable and practically
invisible aligners to help straighten
your teeth
so right now isaac is wearing his braces
and he's not loving it because you know
it's it's right there like you can't
remove them every little mouth
yeah so every time he's eating he has to
take off because he has to put rubber
bands in he has to take off his rubber
bands
he has food stuck in there it's not the
greatest and so
if anything he keeps telling me like man
i wish i got a liners but
for you guys for you guys you get to
straighten your teeth in the comfort of
your own home
with candid because your treatment is
prescribed and closely monitored
remotely by a licensed orthodontist
who's an expert in tooth movement you'll
have the same quality
of care you'd get from an in-office
orthodontist
from the comfort and convenience of your
own home and while other companies use
general dentists candid only works with
orthodontists and with candid the same
orthodontist who created your plan is
with you from start to finish so you'll
never have to wonder how you're doing
the average candid treatment is just six
months
and you'll start seeing results way
before then and it costs thousands less
than traditional braces
and like i said it's so cool you get to
remove them whenever you eat
you don't have to worry about metal
poking inside your mouth
it's really convenient so become your
best you
start straightening your teeth today
right now you can save
75 on candids starter kit
go to candidco.com mood and use
code mood that's candidco.com
mood code mood take advantage of this
limited time offer
to save 75 on your starter kit
candid co.com mood code
mood don't be a loser like isaac [ __ ]
brace face
me too three years some people's teeth
are just too [ __ ] up for clear liners
honestly yeah but um anyways d so do you
guys
um remember the state of mind you were
in
because i know we all kind of said like
maybe we had some pygmy
tendencies as we were growing up yeah
for sure remember
kind of like why like how you got there
and like
because i kind of want to like deprogram
i want to help deprogram girls that are
probably like
offended by this probably because they
are this right now and it's it's like
but hey girl
we were there too right dude for me the
the thing that the reason why
i would have a lot of these thoughts it
stemmed from
insecurity and it was
i mean obviously it's insecurity right
but then what triggered the insecurity
was
the guys that i would like the guys that
i would like or the guys that i would be
around like my guy friends or whatever
they tended to always put other girls
down around me which made me
think that that was um
like it made me program my brain to also
think similarly and then
internalize misogyny yeah exactly
internalize misogyny that's the perfect
way to put it but
also guys that i would date they would
tend to
like spark insecurity within me too
because then they would be like
looking up other girls or like they'll
end up like
freaking breaking their necks when
they're holding my hand like that memes
call training regulation okay right oh
the competition
yeah so then that would make me feel
insecure and like want to know like well
like deep down inside my subconscious
was figuring out like well
you feel this way but maybe it's because
they're
they're just [ __ ] or like they're
they're throwing out their body up
out there for other guys to see and then
it would make me feel like
well [ __ ] like i can't compete with that
because i'm not going to do that and
then it would
have me have these these types of
thoughts that we're talking about in
this episode where
i end up now looking back on it i end up
feeling guilty because i'm like oh [ __ ]
i wish i was smart enough to realize
that that wasn't
needed that wasn't necessary i could
have just um
focused on me and not have to like think
of think negatively of other girls
because they were just doing them like
they were
living their lives being beautiful and
there was no reason for me to have to
hate on that
like you were just around these shitty
guys who were kind of like trying to
make you compete it's almost like they
know that they're not good enough so
they have to make you feel like you have
to grasp
that straws in order to it's like this
kind of like reverse psychology thing i
think guys do
yeah where they like try to get you to
try harder because they know that
actually realistically
we're in control of the dating scene and
they need to try harder but that's like
a really good manipulation technique
i think that guys use especially in
younger girls to get it trying to know
if you guys are aware
i don't think so i don't think they're
aware but i think that's like what's
that's what the subconsciously what's
that's what's happening yeah
it's for me one guy that for sure was
heavily aware
oh yeah like he was aware of what he was
doing so
like you know there were like he'll tell
me like oh i'm gonna pick you up
and go on this date and i'm like okay
cool so
i get ready like seven o'clock comes i'm
like cool i'm ready i'm texting
i'm like hey are you on your way yet
ignores me like nothing
like zero communication and then he ends
up standing me up
and then next thing i know like i'll
i'll check his like
his [ __ ] social media and then i'm
like oh you went to dinner with a
different girl
why do men interesting did you keep
dating him
yeah exactly it works that's exactly the
thing that
well it works on girls that haven't
matured yet right exactly how old were
you
i was young it's okay if you were like
25. it's okay just saying i'm getting it
i was like 21 okay so 20 21 year olds
yeah what happened so this okay so
people got mad at me
for a lot previously i said i don't
think that
girls like even up to 27 28
necessarily should date guys that are 10
years older than them because there's
certain things that men will do
that a young girl in her 20s doesn't
realize how she's kind of being
manipulated
even if it's not intentional like
there's just certain things girls need
to mature out of certain behavior and
thought patterns which
wind up putting them down like holding
them down and suppressing them and a lot
of young girls haven't learned a lot of
things yet i'm hoping now
with all of this discussion and social
media where we can actually share our
knowledge as 30 something year old women
down to the younger girls
um but that's the issue that i have with
like men dating girls that are so much
younger than them is that they can be
manipulated like that so much easier
because he did he treated you like [ __ ]
and you still went for it because it was
it was a manipulation technique and
that's
that's what i try to avoid when young
girls date guys that are so much older
than them there are exceptions though
because i know someone's in the [ __ ]
comments and be like well my man and i
there are exceptions
yeah exception okay look i'm a white
person right let me put let me give this
really
i'm a white person right i'm so [ __ ]
white i have to listen to constantly
all of these negative things that white
people do right but i don't
internalize that because that's not me
when people are talking [ __ ] about white
people that's not me
i did the shoe doesn't fit i don't wear
it so if if our relationship
the [ __ ] we're talking is not your
relationship don't wear the shoe right
yeah so um but anyway i wanted to point
out
the reason why i think i had a lot of
pygmy tendencies when i was younger or
like i was negative towards women i
think started with my mom
i agree the relationship i had with my
mom my mom was a drug addict she was a
she wasn't there all that stuff so i
always felt more comfortable with men i
felt like men were
um just more reliable this and that so i
i believe them yeah i could believe them
so i definitely pushed away
pretty much any female in my life for
most of my life until just probably you
guys and so
i think i unfairly judged women i
unfairly pushed them away put them down
all kinds of stuff because
it was really just coming from the anger
that i had towards my mom
yeah like not being a stable girl so i
think i unfairly
was just always like i don't know i
can't have a relationship with women it
doesn't work out
but my life has never been better since
being able to have relationships with
women because they're more
meaningful and they they're i think
i agree there's life i love women
there's like nothing that
they're trying to lie to get from you
usually so it's kind of yeah we're not
trying to sleep with you guys i know
like you don't want anything
we just love you yeah yeah so i would
say
like yeah i don't know if if you're a
girl
if you're a girl that had a shitty
relationship with her mom and you still
don't have relationships with women
maybe try to
to rethink that get some therapy on that
and like try to get relationships with
women because
it actually is a lot more satisfying for
me we're community based
yes yeah because they're i mean as we
age too i feel like women really need to
have a community because
guys only see our value most not all
uh see our value mostly when we're just
these like young hot things so like when
we get tossed out
into the [ __ ] prairie and girl it's
your turn soon we need to have a
community of women to [ __ ] fall back
on right like we we're not going to
throw each other out just because we're
getting old and saggy
you know what's interesting so um i'm
proud of you
for stepping out of your comfort zone
and seeking relationships with women
and like a lot of times i don't ever
want to put myself as like
i've never been the pikmi girl because
obviously at some point i've been
but i didn't have mommy issues i had
daddy issues
so ever since i was really young same
ever since i was really young
i didn't trust men i didn't take any
word out of their mouth as truth i was
like you're probably lying like if he
was sitting there sit like saying he
like soda i'm like you're [ __ ] lying
piece of [ __ ]
like you probably like water you know so
all men do is live women do is eat [ __ ]
and lie
yeah so i mean obviously that comes with
its own issues and when we have a
daddy's issue episode i would be gladly
back and
share it all out we will hold hands
around the whole thing girl but
um i grew up loving women and i look i
grew up in a matriarchal family
where like my grandma was the one who
called the shots who had 10 daughters
and we would all hang out at all times
and my diaz are all badass
yo it's a loud-ass house isn't it for
sure
it is the gift that they gave me to be a
youtuber because i could talk for days
but um so i grew up watching women be
strong and being reliable and being
loving and being nurturing and with that
sense of community that you're talking
about i grew up with that being my
number one thing
so yeah it's wow but i didn't really
date
until like i was older right and so when
i was in my teens i had like a little
a couple fake boyfriends you know yeah
and i to me my friends were more
important than my boyfriend
and at some point they were like
you [ __ ] you're weird but i was like no
no who cares like he'll be back or like
i'll get another boyfriend
but you were right all along girl i was
the girl that was like why do you care
so much about your friends
well i don't know if like who's right or
who's wrong you know but
it was like now i mean i think maybe
that's why like i have such an easy time
like if anybody does me wrong like
man if men do me wrong i'm like [ __ ]
next i don't need you
yeah i have my support system but with
women i
am like anything you need i will do for
you you're definitely
a girl's girl i am always willing to
always be a girl
that's why is it is it always is it
weird for me to speculate that the women
that are girls girls women's women
are more successful happier like all of
that than the girls that are [ __ ]
like
an island on their own who like only
rely on male attention
i don't know but i will tell you this
like women won't let you down very often
because like we talked about we don't
want to sleep with each other
for them and you know there's about the
ones that are like because i do feel
like there are some girls that are like
they haven't really quite clicked in
that women's only kind of mentality so
like they'll still
like try to tear you down compete with
you so i don't think it's
like even further back because it took
me a long time to trust men again and
finally i'm at a point where like i can
trust men i'm in love with the man
i love him i can finally like uplift
them and hold the space for him in my
life
um i do think men are needed men are
needed and good
like a good quality man who loves you is
a blessing
my god like it is a blessing right but
um
yeah like being a girl's girl and having
a man who supports that about you i
think is like the golden standard
like one like if you have your community
of women that love you and support you
and you have a man who fits really good
into that and this is just the ultimate
goal
i think so that's a really good like i
see it in my diaz the ones that are
married and get along
and their husbands get along with all my
other diaz
i'm like okay i feel like that's what i
should aim for yeah you know like
he like he met like jokes around with
all of us and like he gets along with
everybody they've lasted years together
so
that's what i try to duplicate but you
know like i have a really clear and i
know there's exceptions but
men are not my friends i will not make
friends with yeah yeah i don't have like
platonic
i know i don't have any male friends is
that is that because you don't
believe that is possible or just because
you truly find it really hard
to think that that is possible because i
have tons of like platonic male 1 like
true meaningful relationships like you
do with these girls or like
really yeah do they want to sleep with
you no are you sure
yeah but you're not very aware when
people want to sleep with you though
yeah
you have history we've witnessed like
several guys falling over
themselves to be i
there's an exception but if given the
opportunity
seven times out of ten and that's not
like a written statistic but
you know the majority doesn't feel like
i do think they will end up sleeping
with you like if there was no line to
cross
let me rephrase sure they if the
opportunity was there if i just showed
up like yo let's [ __ ]
then probably would but they don't
friend [ __ ] but they don't
actively try like that's not their goal
they're just like yeah she's my friend
girl i am on the spectrum of the lgbt
community if you were like oh i want to
sleep with you i'd be like no [ __ ]
you're my friend i'm not going to sleep
with you
men can't give you that well the
majority and again it's like a weird
thing to talk about and i think it
deserves its own podcast
but i have other girlfriends that are
like oh they're all my friends and i'm
like [ __ ] they don't want to [ __ ] you
like how are you
or well i guess they're not driven by
that does it matter i guess is maybe why
you don't really care like if they would
take that opportunity
does it matter to you well i see it as
like i'm [ __ ] hot of course
yeah you know but i still don't want to
sleep with you well you know
but sexual preference too that's the
thing
oh yeah she would yeah if i was
yeah like if i wasn't yeah like it's
just like because we have a friendship
i wouldn't break that you know like
unless i was pursuing an actual
relationship
with you and you know like i was like
gina i just really like you and like
i think that we can make great things
happen but if we were drunk
and you like came on to me i'd be like
you need to relax what's happening
even though we're so close and i feel
like the majority of straight males
the majority again not at all yeah would
take that opportunity
okay so for me i think i see it as um
how do i phrase this i see them as
friends and i i am comfortable with it
sure like if i were to
present the opportunity they would they
would because i mean it's me i'm [ __ ]
dope
um but i like them because
like we're friends because it's not the
driving factor behind our friendship
so you think it's not like i know for
sure it's not because i've had these
friends for like 12 years yeah you're
just like genuinely
enjoying your hobbies but i think like i
think
that's you you know you're like well
this works for me she has a lot of
hobbies that
guys do it right away so it's probably
easy for them to like
hang out together right and i think
there's no black and white like it's
right and it's wrong you know like if it
works for you
like yeah who wouldn't want to have a
bunch of people who want to [ __ ] you
around
you doing things for you and like
praising you
um like would you sleep with me they're
like i would rather [ __ ] throw up in
my own [ __ ] face right now than ever
see you naked you know so there's
it's like a brother sister that's where
that's where it is the brother-sister
relationship
for me it's like my my close guy friends
are
they're more like brothers like and then
because i was thinking too i was like
well maybe if it's
maybe the the way that this works is
because they are also in a committed
relationship so there's no way anything
would happen with this yes
but i started thinking i'm like well i
do have single male
friends that i would consider like
really good friends so i'm like wait
that's not the
the the i personally don't have any male
friends that aren't
even married yeah right that's my only
male friends are y'all's husbands
yeah i mean besides like our producer
you know like but that's like
a working relationship yeah those aren't
like people are really a friend and then
he's like i love you jesus and then it's
couples friendships yeah
you know like you and your husband are
friends with nikki and her husband
that's like
a group thing you know you're not really
hanging out i mean you could probably
hang out with steve but you know
because yeah like i think about it i'm
like i mean i'm friends with joe like i
hate
i think it's a relationship no he's like
my brother dude like
really close so it's just like yeah like
there are people
in my life that are male that i would
consider really close yeah you know
you're not
going to friends there's no sexual zero
possibility of ever crossing that line
yep
so if you didn't work with joe how often
would you see him and
casey wasn't around um well now things
are
different because you know jess is x so
we're i'm closer i'm closer to jess than
i am with joe now
but well i think you you through the
working relationship that you've had for
like almost a decade now like you've
built like a reliance like you know you
could count on him if you were
[ __ ] if you really needed something
you know he would be there for you if
you if you really needed advice and you
had no one to turn to you know he would
he would take a call
but it's not like you don't share
hobbies like you're not gonna hang out
together go shopping joe like you're my
best because literally
uh just uh two weeks ago i was like dude
let's go hiking
so i'm like i would hang out with joe
alone you know yeah
like there are there are typically
though most of most of the guys and most
of the girls aren't really sharing
hobbies that make them natural
friends yeah yeah i can see that but
there are certain people like gina she
has hobbies that a lot of guys love
yeah the last the last guy that i met
that said um i don't believe in platonic
relationships with another female
turned out to be a psychotic piece of
[ __ ] i'm not a psychotic piece of [ __ ]
but not you like you're a [ __ ]
intelligent great woman thank you yeah
yeah i just love women right
yeah when it comes from a guy maybe it's
a little weird where they're like
oh a girl has to [ __ ] me or i can't
right like i guess i could see how that
gets a little weird
i don't believe it i don't i don't think
it's wrong for guys and girls to be
friends i just personally don't have any
because i don't have any
common interests with men maybe we're
not [ __ ] like i don't i agree i don't
care about your
whatever i i only care because you're
having sex with me that's the only
reason why
[Laughter]
no i'm just kidding no i mean but the
male friends that i have like y'all's
husbands i do consider them to be very
valuable in my life
because i know that there there is a
barrier where that's never that line's
never going to be crossed
one because we're friends two because
you're married so there's two barriers
to why that line would never be crossed
and then i can actually have
you know a meaningful relationship with
a male who you know i could get their
perspective i can
you know like i enjoy being around male
that feels safe
[ __ ] yesterday so i'm down for that
yeah i
i don't know casey two i don't know if i
can relate
to that you know but also a lot most of
my friends are single
so i do pray for the day and i wait for
the day where they have like
good quality men to bring around yeah it
feels good to have yeah
have a group of quality men in your life
because it helps you remember that
they're not all trash
yeah i agree and like i said men are
needed and i do
value them but i just i don't have a
need for friendship with men i love
women
yeah yeah it's pretty cool i mean
everybody's
life choices are their own um just don't
put other people down
for theirs i guess that's the takeaway
the pick me is like you don't have to
put yourself on a pedestal in order to
get a date like you really do we need a
whole other hour
just for real i really do because like
it's still i feel like i still
sometimes have those tendencies but then
i'm just like pull it back yeah you just
got a [ __ ] ball yeah just think about
it like if you had to put another woman
down you're begging
a dude to pick you like literally please
pick me like [ __ ] no you're good all on
your own
you could just stand there and somebody
will pick you you do not need to
bring other people down to be picked i
think the hard part is that
it feels like you know we know like dick
is abundant you go on a dating app you
can get
dick in like five minutes or less like
but there's a
small amount of what feels like quality
men and i don't just mean rich men
i mean guys that are literally genuinely
helpful
supportive not liars yeah so
it just feels like we're fighting we're
like crabs in a bucket
you know like trying to we're all like
trying to pull each other down in order
to get up because there's like
five percent good guys left so i think
that's where that's coming from but i
don't that's it's not gonna help
i actually think it there's also a
percentage of women out there that
aren't even
realizing that they're doing it like
it's not even
with the intention of trying to get a
man you think you can do it for fun not
even no not even for fun it's just like
self-esteem the insecurity and like the
only way i'm going to feel better about
myself is if i
i talk [ __ ] about that girl over there
that looks amazing like i feel like you
literally you're wasting your time
like get up earlier and start working
and you're amazing like do your hair do
you
like yeah you know what i mean like that
[ __ ] is not going to stop being hot
it's just so much easier to talk [ __ ]
right yeah it's asking for a lot to make
me wake up early
do what you need to do you are a hot
looking woman
you know you don't really have a lot of
room are you putting women down i don't
know
right sometimes yeah
no i mean that's something that i think
a lot of these other women because i'm
i'm
trying to picture the audience member
sitting here and being like yeah i don't
give a [ __ ] about a man i got a man like
like you know and still like putting but
maybe if they feel like in order to keep
him they have to like still
like yeah this i'm separating myself
from that you better stay because look
i'm this
yeah shaking her ass i'm over here being
faithful
exactly go shake your ass yeah go shake
your ass please
if you feel like you have to to compete
that hard with other women i feel like
you're with the wrong guy
i agree yeah i agree that's what it
comes down to
yeah but anyways all right guys well
that's our hour um make sure you go
follow stacy she has
a wealth of knowledge and a ton of
content bringing the translator your own
show with your sister too right
we have a podcast but it's a lot it's a
lot it's a lot
it's just go to my youtube channel and
you'll see the whole train wreck
happening but it's it's going well
it's going where it needs to go shut up
your youtube channel oh yes well
you guys can look me up stay cds you can
look that up and a bunch of videos will
come up click on one
fill out the vive and if you want to
subscribe go ahead no pressure i don't
like dead subscribers and if you
would like to join go ahead and join
yeah we love that all right guys and the
best way to support this show
as usual is to visit our sponsors use
our codes these are links
um that's how we get paid so anyways
leave us
leave us five stars on itunes thumbs up
like the video share the video tell your
mama tell everyone comment i'll talk
[ __ ] in the comments with you
yeah i like to talk [ __ ] back to
especially all the guys in there i'm
like you know what go [ __ ] yourself just
kidding love you i love the good ones
there's some good ones out there there's
a few um anyways all right
we'll see you guys next week thank you
bye